When we're going to implement the most simple controller I may think of? A p-type controller.
P stands for proportional.
It's simply going to multiply the error by some number to produce the input for the brake.
To be more concrete, let's multiply the error with 100,000 m/s².
When doing so, we can, of course, get huge positive and negative numbers
that don't make any sense to control the brake so we have to clamp the output.
Whenever the result of that multiplication is negative, we return 0 instead.
Whenever the result of that multiplication is larger than 200 m/s², we return 200 m/s².
Why could that possibly work?
Assume that when we're fitting this controlled value of 130 m/s² into the brake,
we're actually ending up with the wheel slip of 0.1987.
And the difference between the optimum value and the actual value is 0.00130.
The controller is going to return the same number again, 130 m/s².
So this foot constitutes an equilibrium.
One thing to know about this naive version of the p-type controller is
that the value of the equilibrium is always slightly less than the optimum.
If anything changes concerning the dynamics of the car or the vault conditions,
this actual value may change.
When the actual wheel slip goes up a little, the difference is going to decrease.
We're subtracting the actual wheel slip. This is going to become 0.00129.
The error gets a little smaller. We're multiplying this error by 100,000 m/s², which results in 129 m/s².
We're braking less, at least we're braking less hopefully. The slip is going to decrease again.
So this looks like a stable equilibrium at least from the one side,
but obviously, this also works when the actual wheel slip is a little too low.
Now implement this in Python. Your first job is to implement the p control as a function.
The function receives the actual value and the target value, 0.2 that is,
and returns the output of the p control, which eventually controls the brake.
Your second job is to call that function to control the brake.